AND THAT INCLUDES THE MEDIA.
IT ALSO MAY WANT TO LAWYER UP,
A NUMBER OF THEM.
JOINING US WITH REACTION, JIM
JORDAN, SARA CARTER, LET'S
START WITH YOUR REPORT.
LET'S STAY ON THE FACTS HERE.
I SPOKE TO THREE PEOPLE, TWO
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS, ONE
LEVELS THAT 100% THE DOSSIER
WAS USED AT LEAST IN PART, ONE
PERSON SAID WAS SIGNIFICANTLY A
PART OF GETTING THE FISA
WARRANT.
WHAT ARE YOU REPORTING TONIGHT?
>> I'M REPORTING THE SAME.
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL, AND
ANOTHER IN THE D.O.J., AND THE
DOSSIER WAS ABSOLUTELY USED AS
PART OF THE F.B.I.'S ABILITY TO
GAIN A WARRANT TO BASICALLY SPY
ON MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
SO THIS WAS DEFINITELY USED AS
EVIDENCE.
IT WAS PART AND PARCEL TO OTHER
HERE, SEAN, IS THE FACT THAT WE
KNOW COMING FROM THE MOUTHS OF
MEMBERS, SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
F.B.I. WHO TESTIFIED BOTH COMEY
AND MCCABE, THE ONLY PART OF
THE DOSSIER THEY WERE ABLE TO
CONFIRM THAT WAS ACTUALLY
FACTUAL WAS THAT CARTER PAGE
HAD TRAVELED TO MOSCOW.
EVERYTHING ELSE IN THE DOSSIER
APPARENTLY THEY DID NOT TALK
ABOUT THAT, THEY DID NOT
CONFIRM.
IT IS UNSUBSTANTIATED OR FOUND
OUT TO BE FALSE.
SO THIS IS VERY ALARMING AND I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF SOURCES THAT ARE ALARMED
ABOUT THIS, PARTICULARLY PEOPLE
WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE
CONCERNED THAT THEY WERE USING
THIS DOSSIER TO FIND A WAY TO
LOOK INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS.
JIM THE FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE
FREEDOM CONFERENCE.
I MUST GO TO THE CURRENT
CHAIRMAN FIRST.
ARE YOU GETTING THE SAME
CONFIRMATION THAT WE'RE GETTING?
>> OBVIOUSLY, SEAN, TALKING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IN A
CONFIDENTIAL SETTING IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE ALLOWED TO DO.
I WILL SAY THIS.
THERE IS A GROWING BODY OF
MEMBERS WHO BELIEVE THAT THIS
DOSSIER WAS A SIGNIFICANT
FACTOR, AS YOU WERE MENTIONING,
SOME SAYING IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
FACTOR IN TERMS OF THE FISA
WARRANT.
BUT I THINK THAT THERE IS A
BROADER QUESTION HERE.
WHY WOULD THE F.B.I. USE A
DEMOCRAT PAID FOR DOSSIER TO
ACTUALLY SURVEIL ANOTHER
CAMPAIGN?
>> Sean: ISN'T IT WORSE THAN
THAT?
I WAS TALKING TO GREGG JARRETT.
A LAWYER, OFFICER OF THE COURT
VIOLATING THE LAW BY KNOWINGLY
USING DECEPTIVE DOCUMENTS TO
DESERVE THE COURT?
>> EXACTLY.
SO IT IS NOT ONLY TROUBLING
THERE BUT I THINK IT'S TIME,
JIM JORDAN AND I ARE HERE
TONIGHT TO CALL ON OUR
OUTSTANDING WORK THAT CHAIRMAN
NUNES HAS PUT FORTH IN
GATHERING DOCUMENTS.
EVERY MEMBER HAS ACCESS TO
THOSE DOCUMENTS AND WE'RE
CALLING ON OUR LEADERSHIP TO
MAKE THAT AVAILABLE.
>> Sean: THAT WOULD MEAN THE
SPEAKER, KEVIN MCCARTHY, JIM
JORDAN?
THAT THE CHORUS WILL GROW AND
SAY MAKE IT PUBLIC SO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND
ONCE AND FOR ALL WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED.
REMEMBER, SEAN, IT'S TODAY, ONE
YEAR ANNIVERSARY WHEN BUZZ FEED
PRINTED THE ENTIRE DOSSIER, THE
SALACIOUS UNVERIFIED DOSSIER AS
JIM COMEY TESTIFIED AND SAID IT
WAS.
ONE YEAR AGO TODAY THEY PRINTED
IT.
A YEAR AND A HALF TO GO THEY
WENT TO THE FISA COURT TO GET
THE WARRANT.
LET'S MAKE IT AVAILABLE FOR
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO SEE.
ADMISSIBLE IN A COURT.
IF HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
DOSSIER IS USED TO OBTAIN A
FISA WARRANT?
WHAT HAPPENS THEN?
>> THERE ARE THREE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS.
DID THE F.B.I. PAY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, THE AUTHOR OF THE
DOSSIER, DID THEY USE THAT.
>> Sean: I'M HEARING FROM
SOURCES THAT EITHER COMEY OR
MCCABE PAID.
DO YOU HEAR THE SAME?
>> I'M HEARING BOTH STORIES,
THIS.
WE ARE HEARING THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY DID PAY.
I'M HEARING FROM OTHER SOURCES
THAT THEY DID NOT PAY.
QUESTION AND THE CONGRESS
SHOULD BE ASKING THIS.
>> Sean: WHAT'S POINT NUMBER
TWO?
>> THAT'S WHY WE WANT THE
DOCUMENTS MADE AVAILABLE TO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
WE'RE ALL ENTITLED TO SEE THIS.
MAKE IT AVAILABLE.
GIVE US THE INFORMATION.
NUNES HAS DONE GREAT WORK IN
GETTING THESE DOCUMENTS.
NOW COMING TO INTEL.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE MORE MEMBERS
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE NEED TO MAKE THIS AVAILABLE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SO THEY
CAN SEE WHAT TOOK PLACE HERE.
HAPPEN, THAT SURE IS WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE.
LET'S FIND OUT FOR CERTAIN.
>> Sean: LET'S GO BACK FUSION
GPS NEVER VERIFIED THE DOSSIER.
THEY TRIED TO WITHHOLD WHO PAID
FOR THE DOSSIER AND BANKING
RECORDS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
THE "WASHINGTON POST" FIRST
REVEALED THE DNC AND HILLARY
CLINTON CAMPAIGN HAD PAID
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO FUSION
GPS TO BASICALLY GO AFTER THIS
TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION
NARRATIVE AND WHEN THEY HIRED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND WHEN HE
WENT BACK TO SOME OF HIS OLD
FORMER SPY IN THE FSB AND THIS
IS WHY THESE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED.
THE RUSSIANS COULD HAVE VERY
EASILY ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES
PAID FOR BY THE DNC AND THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THEY COULD HAVE USED IT FOR
THEIR OWN PROPAGANDA PURPOSES.
IT APPEARS THEY HAVE.
NOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS WHAT
WAS THE AMOUNT OF THIS SYSTEMIC
ABUSE?
WAS THERE SYSTEMIC ABUSE WITH
THE FISA WARRANT?
IS IT JUST RELATED TO THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN OR
DOES IT GO BEYOND?
>> Sean: IT WOULD RENDER
ANYTHING THEY'VE GOT
INADMISSIBLE.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN TRYING TO
SELL "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORT.
GREGG JARRETT MADE A GOOD POINT
YORK TIMES" REPORTING THAT
PAPADOPOULOS MOUTHED OFF TO AN
AUSTRALIAN DIPLOMAT HE HEARD
THE RUSSIANS HAD DIRT ON
HILLARY.
THAT'S NOT EVEN ADMISSIBLE.
TESTIMONY.
I SAY LET'S GO AHEAD AND
RELEASE IT ALL TO ALL THE
MEMBERS.
IF THERE IS NOTHING THAT IS OF
NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST,
THEN LETS RELEASE IT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND LET THEM BE
THE JUDGE.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION, NOTHING
TO HIDE.
LET'S GET IT OUT THERE.
AUSTRALIAN DIPLOMAT WHO TELLS
THE F.B.I.
LET'S PLAY PHONE TAG.
>> NOW THAT'S THE REASON THEY
LAUNCHED THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION?
NOT THE DOSSIER WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT FOR THE LAST YEAR?
IT'S PAY NO ATTENTION TO THE
MAN BEHIND THE CURTAIN.
THAT'S A LAUGHABLE STORY.
WE KNOW WHAT'S CAUSED THIS AND
THE STUFF WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Sean: I'M HEARING AND
GETTING RUMBLINGS OF THIS THAT
SOME OF THE DETAILS ARE BEYOND
OUR IMAGINATION IN TERMS OF
SHAKING HIS HEAD.
THAT THE F.B.I. AND D.O.J.
WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOW IT TO
HAPPEN AND I WOULD ALSO SAY
>> Sean: WE'VE BEEN RIGHT ALL
ALONG?
>> YOU'RE OVER THE TARGET AND
WE'RE FOCUSING IN ON THAT
TONIGHT.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
THE TRUTH, THEY NEED TO KNOW
THE TRUTH AND BE ABLE TO FIND
RESOLUTION TO THIS SO THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OUR NATION
CAN MOVE FORWARD.
AND THAT THEY ARE NOT STUCK IN
THIS FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA HAS BEEN
WRONG THE ENTIRE TIME.
JIM, YOU ARE SMILING.
LAST COMMENT WE'LL GIVE TO YOU.
>> NO, SARAH WAS GREAT.
WE'LL LET MEMBERS SEE IT.
LET MEMBERS SEE IT AND THEN LET
THE PUBLIC SEE IT.